on a rarement vu autant de feux brûlés
en même temps dans la forêt amazonienne
plus de 80 mille feux ont été recensés
depuis janvier
la très grande majorité brûle depuis
deux semaines une hausse de 84% par
rapport à l'an dernier
pendant qu'on accuse les gros
producteurs bovins et de brûler les
arbres et de provoquer une déforestation
massive
les petits agriculteurs se défendent un
nouveau super g à val d'isère c'est un
cross arkema il faille aux malades de
tout cet amour à dire poursuit pour qui
tout noir à ces moments là dieu nous
sommes donc pas aux guinéens passe de
rooney six fermiers ne comprennent pas
pourquoi tout d'un coup la planète les
accuse des pires fléaux pour eux ces
feux ne sont pas exceptionnelles en 2013
encore plus d'hectares avaient été
apparemment brûlées une déforestation
encourager à l'époque par le président
lula da silva qui donnait ses terres à
des pauvres pour qu'ils puissent
cultiver
ils brûlent les arbres pour faire des
pâturages cas vous aux consommateurs les
produits danger je sais maintenant je
deviens monster mène donc sa page psg je
vais
président d'un sonar on poursuit
l'oeuvre de ses prédécesseurs
weight des perses et proverbes depuis
les années 1970
des milliers de paysans ont été envoyés
en amazonie pour y développer
l'agriculture mais jamais ces petits
fermiers n'aurait cru être un jour au
coeur d'une crise diplomatique sans
précédent entre les présidence
brésilienne et française qu'ils tiennent
des propos extraordinairement et
respectueux à l'égard de mon épouse le
président macron n'a pas apprécié cette
publication qui dénigrent sa femme un
humour douteux qui a fait rire le
président brésilien
comme j'ai beaucoup d'amitié de respect
pour le peuple brésilien j'espère très
rapidement qu'ils auront un président
qui se comporte à la hauteur malgré
l'affront le président français a tenu à
aider le brésil
il a convaincu les leaders du g 7
d'offrir des millions de dollars pour
aider les pays de l'amazonie à lutter
contre ces incendies pourraient aggraver
le réchauffement climatique
une offre rejetée aujourd'hui par le
président moh sonar ou pics de 12 à
faire on n'a rien compris le g7 dit il
on a des problèmes avec un des
présidents du g7
emmanuel macron l'accusent de mentir sur
ses engagements climatiques bord sonar
ou lui demande de retirer ses insultes
sinon le brésil va refuser l'aide
offerte l'aide internationale 17 ans ne
doit pas primer l'autonomie du brésil
sur l'amazonie cette femme elle
s'inquiète de voir le brésil isolé
on ne peut pas vivre les grandit aux
vitesses si on est seul de notre côté
toute aide est la bienvenue
si elle est bien intentionnés surtout
qu'en ce moment on manque d'espoir ici
sophie langlois radio canada montréal